Michaels in Lubbock Texas hey Michael
how are you
greetings from Red Raider country how
are you sir better than I deserve how
can I help um well we are on we will
finish baby step for Friday at 3:00
maybe baby I'm sorry I don't know baby
step three Friday great and so I have a
question I have a really smart wife like
ridiculously smart and she's really hot
that's really smart how do I save for
Christmas for her for her for gifts for
her when she's in charge of the budget
and sees everything that I spent and
he's cash for what sounds like there's
but sounds like there's a budget line
item for gifts but I don't want her to
know how much the gift is and how and
where I'm getting from well I didn't say
you had to get it from but she's gonna
know how much it is because you're
agreeing on your budget I'm trying to
figure out how to how to stay for
Christmas without her knowing what I'm
getting and only what we don't have to
use cash we don't have credit cards you
know does that make sense
yeah but we're all grown-ups here this
is not a child dealing with it's your
wife yes I know she knows if she she
doesn't have to know what you're buying
or even where you're going to shop she
can just allocate the you know when you
to do your budget together both of you
know what we are spending on gifts and
if she's gonna do the Christmas shopping
accept the portion that you do yeah
we're gonna agree that this is how much
we're spending and she's gonna give you
that and if you if you want it in cash
that's fine and that way you can spend
it but yeah we're just all gonna be
grownups and we're gonna know what's
going on here I mean you don't get to go
spend like just rob the money out of the
budget just go buy your wife something I
mean sorry that would be sweet but it's
just not it's not good medicine it's and
I don't work for you especially since
she's kind of the budget Queen she's not
gonna like that